[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lesen
eine ferien lodge mitten in der pampa
von hubei wurde althaus treibt vor ort
das projekt voran führt verhandlungen
und kaufte eine baumaschine
während susanne in der schweiz weiterhin
geld für ihren auswanderer traum
verdient vorerst in der schweiz bleiben
auch die kinder der familie kunst die
eltern übernehmen an der nordsee einen
imbisswagen mit würsten und von fritz
also fiel zum beispiel pommes pizza
pommes auf ein hotel und mehr zeit für
die familie
dieser traum soll sich für die alma das
in kanada verwirklichen
[Musik]
sie kämpfen mit den tücken des alltags
und empfangen die ersten gäste
[Musik]
der tag beginnt früh für beatrice und
josef almeida
es reicht für einen kurzen kaffee dann
geht es ab ins hotel
es ist sommer saison bewusst sind
[Musik]
ich mache das gern auf eingeschlagen und
gar nicht alles machen laufen dann
schlussendlich wurde
natürlich weiß auch schöne wochenend
können schlaffe so früh aufstehen müssen
auch die kinder sophie andré und robin
obwohl die langen sommerferien begonnen
haben
sie begleiten ihre eltern zum motto
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein exquisites frühstück für die gäste
mit viel selbst gemacht
das legten almeidas am herzen mutter
beatrice ist gelernte köchin und die
kinder helfen mit
rufe mit comic band homepage
die sprache ist so freundlich zu
seit der eröffnung vor drei monaten
arbeitet das ehepaar almeyda sieben tage
die woche
dabei wollten die beiden hier in kanada
eigentlich mehr zeit mit der familie
verbringen und nun das
freue mich die donnerstag
ich habe tipps machen und ausleben
das versteht er es nicht auf die
wissenschaft und technologie dennoch
passen
widerstand
darauf haben
aber so schnell können sich die albers
keine pause und immer kommt noch was
dazu trotz hochsaison wollen sie die
gäste zimmer renovieren das zimmer
wollen sie streichen lassen
altes muss neuem platz machen
100 möbelstücke zum selber zusammenbauen
haben sie sich liefern lassen
alle 18 zimmer sollen neue möbel
bekommen
ungemütlich machen machen wir das ja
[Musik]
jahrelang war die stürmische nordsee die
liebste feriendestinationen der familie
kunz jetzt werden sie hierzu unternehmen
gut 4000 euro investierten sie in die
beschriftung ihres geschäftes den küsten
[Gelächter]
thomas peter der vorbesitzer führte sie
bereits in die grill küche ein
und die betriebsbewilligung haben sie
problemlos erhalten eine große macht der
schüler kommen zwei stunden oder so aber
regisseur schnitt nötig und wir
weltbewegend die geschäfte aber
sozusagen um die gegangen glaubt das ist
also ich nicht speziell sehr viel machen
lang handwäsche einfach mehr braucht man
nicht
also durchaus mit alkoholausschank
braucht man nicht mehr und so machen
glück haben sollte so winterhalter und
relativ konkret haltbarkeit tara folie
das ist eine zahl bis zwölf jahre
hoffmann hätte 12 fuß doch er hat sich
schon als baby das ist auch mein start
und am kritik und hoffe ja dass europa
league träumen
[Musik]
noch ist rudi althaus alleine in europa
seit wochen arbeitet der 53 jährige dann
täglich auf seinem grundstück seinem
witz die wichtigste baumaschine ist
dabei ist ein radlader
fünf lange wochen hatte er auf die
lieferung von baggerschaufel und arm
gewartet jetzt machen
[Musik]
in knapp zwei jahren soll hier ein
kleines ferienparadies entstehen dann
wird ruhe die der bau schreiner zum
gastgeber
aber das funktioniert funktioniert
er muss keine daten nennen
[Musik]
noch im emmental ist seine so sein
sie ist in die einliegerwohnung ihres
hauses gezogen dass sie mittlerweile
vermietet haben täglich bekommt sie
nachrichten aus uruguay und dieser gelbe
wohncontainer wird schon bald ihr neues
zuhause sein schon lange bereitet sich
susan auf die auswanderung vor und
besucht seit zwei jahren einen
spanischkurs nur noch wenige wochen dann
kann sie in uruguay zeigen was sie
gelernt hat
[Musik]
die auswanderer kinder robin und audrey
sind in thematisch gut aufgenommen
worden
innert kurzer zeit haben sie freunde
gefunden
in den dreimonatigen sommerferien haben
sie zeit sich noch besser kennenzulernen
das engagement und die gastfreundschaft
der neuen besitzer zahlen sich aus das
hotel ist ausgelastet
neben den reinigungs hilfen haben die
alba das seit kurzem auch eine
rezeptionistin stundenweise angestellt
ich bin in der mitte will muss ist
studierte eigentlich entspricht der 3
sprache und aber werde vor allem
entlastet sie uns oder so haben wir aber
auch die familie leben und kentaur
defizite weil sie nicht immer wie es am
juni im hotel lohnzahlung die öffentlich
immer am mittwoch wenn sie einen scout
die form eines checks von der büroarbeit
bis zu den kleinen ärgernissen des
alltags die meiste arbeit nehmen alle
mal dass selbst in die hand
der griff einer wc spülung ist kaputt im
keller stehen noch alte toiletten ein
kleines ersatzteillager
[Musik]
geschafft der neue alte griff ist
montiert sehr gehofft und diakonie und
wo ist meine stimme hat oder takt wippt
es funktioniert wirklich buch wo denn
die grube löst oder was eine ganz so ist
da eigentlich nur gott weiß ja wenn man
so was mode stelle hat so wie es ist
auch keine klarmachen
es hat dann ist das macht uns nicht uns
hier und seite nicht einfach
[Musik]
es ist august und winter als susan in
uruguay ankommt wo die war kurzerhand in
die schweiz geflogen um sie abzuholen
mit dabei kategorie so schnell wie
möglich fahren die emmentaler zu ihrem
witz ihrem grundstück
ähnlich extrem schauen
die und das umland doch sie sich jetzt
das morgenessen
[Musik]
das ist ein ko system
was die 52-jährige von hunderten von
fotos kennt ist plötzlich wirklichkeit
und dann noch eine überraschung
ihre freunde mag und elisabeth zwei
ausgewanderte zürcher sind
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das ist es also ihr provisorisches
zuhause
der gelbe wohncontainer er sich mit dem
hsv oder vielmehr bewusst wurde dass es
zukünftig aber hey man ist ja sehr gut
das mit der herr ackermann plötzlich
sehen die sie ja aber ich gut
die zahl auch curry erwartet eine
überraschung katze dickel sie lebt schon
lange auf dem biz
[Musik]
und diese mission
alles okay heißt timo betriebsrat haben
sich spezielle wärme aus dem salon app
ist so sind noch sind die kinder der
familie kunst auf kreta in den ferien in
einer woche werden auch sie nach dorum
kommt und sascha haben kaum zeit die
kinder zu vermissen
denn schon steht das grillgut vor der
tür
danke
normal fällt die unersetzliche erste
liebe und die klage des berufs sprachen
war gerade weil er öffentlich gesprochen
und das hochland noch um 30 grad vor
gericht
richtig heißt 200 kilo pommes frites und
zwar frische keine tiefgefrorenen und
das von einem lieferanten der alles frei
haus liefert die garage ist der
kuehlhaus foren ist in der qualitativ
sicher länger haltbar aber mit buchen
relativ fit und verdammt angeboten
unsere neue buch aber plötzlich
für die wahl der perfekten grillwurst
luden sie deutsche freunde zum
probeessen 108 damit ist die richtige
kurzerhand haben sie 1000 würste
geordert es ist spät es ist
wir haben uns schön denn ich glaube
davon dass ich sie da er sich so alles
nicht wirklich sagen hier ist das geld
abholen und ja danke schön dass wir
haben uns schön was du tun
ja das war wird auch super danke dir
[Musik]
für einmal sind die all my das nicht am
arbeiten im velmoré-hotel hat
rezeptionistin wilma dienst die
gemeinsame freizeit zu hause genießen
das schaffen die alma das nie lange auch
hier gibt es immer etwas zu tun
das dach ist undicht
das ist ja einfach so besprochen dass
ich jetzt machen was ich habe eben
ständig immer einen cowboy
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute fährt die ganze familie ans meer
an der bluse beach wollen all my dass
ein paar stunden abschalten
doch allen gelingt das nicht
als viertes gold denken denken
ich sagte ja und dumm
wir suchen immer wieder am start aber
nur vier stunden zwei oder her und schon
bilder vielleicht die zwei größten ohne
ganzen tag für die häufige sie alle
das ist herrlich herrlich ganz still
selbststudium sie ist einfach da
[Musik]
ich möchte
gut überlegt ist halb geklebt nur stimmt
was da steht
[Musik]
eigentlich war es wirklich links anders
aber so aber bitte rechts an stellen
heisst mehr alters das terrain ist und
das ist dir sicher vorne und noch und
muss wirklich sagen und das projekt ist
es auch besitzen im inneren einig ist
das falsch eigentlich war es wirklich
links heute ist das nebensache
wichtiger sind die preise hier
grillwagen muss künftig die ganze
familie ernähren
[Musik]
multipliziert
mit spezielle programme die haben zum
einen durch die zerschneidung sekunde im
internet und noch mit einer stilberatung
nachwirkt die preise der schweizer
interessieren auch margret sie ist
besitzerin des trinkbrunnen dem wagen
liegen an
wir passen uns hoffe ist erstmal ein
paar beginnt
[Musik]
für margret ist familie kunst keine
konkurrenz einem erfolgreichen
eröffnungstag steht also nichts mehr im
weg dann machen wir die 15 stunden kurz
also war damals vor ihm 26 mal afrika
und natürlich vorbereitet so felix loch
wird die nacht was auch wirklich als key
player durch und das soll also sie und
ihr mann alles parat meines curry sauce
[Musik]
sonnenschein aber nur acht grad die
erste nacht im container ist vorüber
[Musik]
ich suchte ganz nach moskau zu schicken
bis der erste bungalow steht wohnen die
beiden auf knapp 14 quadratmetern ja
morgen aufgestanden habe ich eine chance
für komische sachen stecken
jung sagte von ihm ausgestellt ja jetzt
kriegt sofort die patientin ist es
wichtig sie sind ein paar zähne nach
platz war das gut
wer stürzt das café unterstützt den
beschluss
llamazares gestoßen ist jetzt dass
glocken löschen
diese marke durch
reinigung gesagt
dort wurde dann mit dem bett lag
[Musik]
die gemeinschaft der alma das wird immer
größer oft sitzen angestellte und
freunde der kinder gemeinsam am
mittagstisch
noch haben die alm alters eine art
probezeit status in kanada ihre
aufenthaltsbewilligung ist vorläufig
noch befristet und an einen vertrag
geknüpft erfüllen sie den vertrag können
sie in zwei jahren das aufenthaltsrecht
beantragen
die bestehenden aufstellten übernehme
plusminus normaler brief stellen und mir
hat jetzt ein grüner politik stellt und
während das einkaufs- oder fünf mehr
oder weniger und sie wollen bleiben die
ganze familie sputet sich um das erste
renovierte zimmer fertig einzurichten
[Musik]
wichtig ist dass ich wollte erst richtig
einfach da sauber und ich sage jetzt
schon jetzt will ich mich doch lieber
jetzt will ich geschlafen
[Musik]
das hätte das und auch werbe für einen
blick über ihren besitz steigen zu sein
und ruhe die auf den höchsten punkt
ihres landes die unendliche weite direkt
vor ihrem container
[Musik]
der wand also hab ich aber ist der
richtige stärke gibt auch 100
betriebsstunden der erste service am
radlager ist fällig nach vier monaten im
land kann ruhe die sich schon
verständlich
damit besitzt konzentration definitiv
nicht
[Musik]
dass ich mich habe ich koche und zuerst
ihr haus in der schweiz hatten sie
selber gebaut deshalb sagt rudi auf den
baumeister zu verzichten
2 marco kurz
marina nigg no way of canada schloss ein
csu-politiker durch die bauerschaft den
neuanfang mit dem betonieren zusammen
die neue architektur wie tenor ihre
kinder stark machen so nahe gekommen wie
nie weiß was ich selber machen was kann
ihr droht eine zweite niere alleine
darum schnell herauswachsen
den ersten bungalow ihrer prosa da
werden die beiden selber beziehen morgen
mit aussicht
sie hoffen schon bald einzuziehen
zusätzliche 3 immer nicht aber das liegt
vielleicht sind wir jetzt weiter geht
dann überlegen
das wetter unter nordsee ist eine
launische sache doch regen ist am
eröffnungstag nicht angekündigt so oder
so brigitta und saschas gute laune kann
heute kein wetter verderben 400 würste
hat er im kühlschrank
das ist ja es ist ein anderer schafft
das ist also aber ich glaube es macht
spaß und man hofft werk blicken
das ist aber sehr wichtig war es gilt
das lied der friedrich sind und und und
und können wir sicher verloren und und
ja hoffentlich zum konsumieren
aber ich denke wenn man so bei 100 zu
helfen
da haben wir kurze fazit vom heutigen
tag und wir sind offen für jeden gast in
der region und vielleicht drei treffer
ist aber auch klasse
voges bringe glück aber nur wenn man ihn
selber bekomme behauptete jedenfalls der
vorbesitzer
[Musik]
ich hab wirtschaft anschieben
zur oberfläche
das ist alles jetzt wo ich musste das
ehepaar kunst hat es gewagt die
einstigen angestellten sind unternehmer
geworden
na ja so super tag und sagt eigentlich
alles gibt und das ist jetzt auch die
halter gehen und die halt der planstraße
und dann kann man warte doch trainer
schaffte jetzt herzlich ob die zweite
hälfte vom anruf machen
[Applaus]
sascha wird langsam nervös
[Musik]
so hofer so wie beraubt nicht mal mit
drei euro aber haben ja noch knapp 17
minuten auf brot und wein und einen
kassensturz am eröffnungstag und das
ehepaar kunz hat ein erstes problem
dann kommen ihre kinder in deutschland
an
in kanada gibt es eine große veränderung
im leben der alm aydas mutter beatrice
fährt für zehn wochen in die schweiz
[Musik]
und abenteuerliches leben auf der
baustelle bei susan packt mit an
wegen dir noch völlig vorsichtiger
das träumen
juli aus
[Musik]
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge